[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه التغطيه
الخاصه على قناه خاصه منكاتو على اسيري
راديو مونت كارلو الدوليه للحدث الكروي
الاهم في العالم المجاله الذي ينظم في
نسخته الثانيه والعشرين في دوله عربيه في
قطر للمره الاولى في تاريخه 22 او 32
منتخب منها اربعه منتخبات عربيه قطر
والسعوديه والمغرب وتونس ستتنافسون حوالي
شهر بهذا في نيللي اللقب الاسمى في كره
القدم تغطيه خاصه خلال ساعه من الوقت
نرافقكم فيها انا وزمي لهذه العجمي ونذهب
خلالها الى قطر انطلاق المباراه
الافتتاحيه مع مدير الخاصين وعثمان طيبين
ومع مراسلين في تونس والمغرب الحديث عن
تطوعات البلدين لهذه المسابقه معنا في
الاستديو سيكون ايضا الزامين في مونت
كارلو الدوليه ادم
ان اخيرا سعد الصفر المونديال القطري همم
ينطلق اذا كما ذكرت منذ قليل هو مونديال
عربي وهناك مشاركه اربع منتخبات عربيه
هناك كثير من الجدل الكثير من الانتقادات
لكن في الاخير ال اا رياضيا عندما نتحدث
رياضيا عن البنيه التحتيه عن الملاعب ااه
يعني التحضيرات الاستعدادات حتى الجنين
فانتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
اكد واكثر من مره ان هذا المونديال يعني
همم على المستوى البنيه التحتيه ينجح حتى
قبل انطلاق المونديال اكد اكثر من مره ان
هذا المونديال سيكون ناجح 100% بما انه
جاء همم قطر اكثر من مره وشاهد البنيه
التحتيه من الداخل وتابع كيفيه همم
الاستعداد لهذا القطري فيما يخص الجدل
دائما كل المواعيد هناك جدلها انتقادات
بالجمله على ما يخص اليد العامله الاجنبيه
التي كانت ساهمت في تشييد
العب همم موندياليه وايضا البنيه التحتيا
كانت طرقات او كيفيه العمل هناك جدله فيما
يخص استهلاك الطاقه ونعلم جيدا ان هناك
ازمه الطاقه خاصه في هذه الفتره همم تضرب
كل العالم بسبب يعني هناك جدل ولكن هذه
الملاعب ودرجه الحراره المرتفعه همم يعني
واستخدام التكييف حتى يكون
الجماهير وايضا الملاعب في همم وايضا هناك
جدل اخر فيما بخص تنظيم هذا المدير في مثل
هذه الفتره وهذا مهم ومهم للغايه حتى نخرج
ونبعث ونبتعد بعض الشيء عن المستوى
السياسي على المستوى الرياضي الان هناك
حتى المدربين المنتخبات على غرار لويس
المدرب المنتخب الهولندي قبل التحول الى
قطر قام بتوجيه انتقادات واثاره كثير من
الاحتفاظات همم فيما يخص تنظيم المونديال
في مثل هذه الفتره وايضا همم
يتواصل حتى بعد الوصول الى المونديال
القطار نتحدث في هذه على كل هذا نقاط
واعتقد اننا نتحول مباشره الى قطر الى
اربطه الاتصال ب وديع في عاني وديع في
عاني معنا من قطر يحدثنا عن الاستعدادات
وهذا الحرف الافتتاحي والمباراه
الافتتاحيه المنتخب القطري المنتخب اهلا
وسهلا
مساء الخير مساء الخير لجميع مساء الخير
هذه مساء الخير دنيا همم
ساعه همم قبل انطلاق المباراه الافتتاحيه
بين قطر هنا في ملعب البيت في مدينه الخور
التي تبعد 35 كلم عن العاصمه الدوحه ملعب
يتسع ل60,000 متفرجه لمتابعه المنتخب
القطري المضيف الذي يشارك في اول مونديال
له في تاريخه
وقبل ذلك حفل الافتتاح ارادوا هنا
المنظمون ان يكون هناك حفل على طريقه
الالعاب الاولمبيه اي حفل الضغط
الاساسيه او عنوان هذا الحفل اللي هو همم
وهي كلمه الضيافه الضيافه العربيه ضيافه
القطريه وهذا الحفل اذا سيكون همم كما
ذكرنا اكبر على الطريقه الاولمبيه وليس
على طريقه همم الحفلات التي دائما نتبعها
قبل المونديال عاده عندما يكون هناك
بطولات عالم ان كان في كره القدم او رياضه
اخرى يكون هناك همم ربما همم حفل صغير
متواضع نسبيا قبل الاعلان الذي هو خوض
المباراه الافتتاح هذه المره هناك حفل
كبير همم يحصل حاليا يدور حاليا في ملعب
البيت خلفي طيب وديعه اهلا بك معنا من
جديد
كان هناك حديث كثير عن توافد المشجعين الى
ان قطر لحضور هذا العرس الكروي همم خلال
الايام الماضيه قي بان عدد المشجعين لم
يكن بالمستوى المعتاد في باقي همم
الموديلات الاخرى لكن امس واول امس بدانا
نشاهد هؤلاء عيب همم المشجعين حديثنا عن
هؤلاء
اذا راينا بعض المشجعين صحيح ومن دون
وصلنا الى المطار بشكل خاص القديمين من
امريكا الجنوبيه مشجعين من البرازيل من
الارجنتين همم
المنتخب الذي المباراه
في روسيا حيث كان هناك همم الاف وعشره
الاف من المشجعين القادمين من جنوب همم من
امريكا الجنوبيه صحيح المسافه بعيده ما
قطرعه بالنسبه للمشجعين العاديين اذا هناك
عدد اقل على مشاهدناه حتى الان ربما يصلون
في الايام القليله قبل قود منتخب الوطني
همم مباراه المباراه الاولى بالنسبه له
هنا على الملعب طبعا سيكون مليء همم
60,000 متفرج من قطر ومن خارج قطر وكان
كثير من همم همم خليجيين جاءوا من الدول
المجاوره وايضا همم القليل همم من مشجعين
المنتخب الاكوادور القديم من الاكوادور
عموما هناك الكثير ايضا همم من اجليات
الاجنبيه الجليات المنتخبات المشاركه في
المونديال التي جاءت من قطر من
الدول المجاوره اكثر بكثير من همم مشجعين
همم يعني من الدول نفسها البعيده شيء همم
هنا الى قطر
حول
استجابات عده حقوق الانسان همم اقامته في
دوله عربيه مساله الكحول هل نتحدثهم الى
بعض المشجعين هل همم اثرت فيهم هذه
السيجالات
بالنسبه للمشجعين الاجانب طبعا هي المساله
ربما تهم اكثر المشجعين الاجانب قضيه
الكحول التي
تفاجئنا بعض شيء باعلان الفيفا ورئيس
الفيفا امس جاني انفانتينو لن يكون هناك
تواجد
الكحول في الملاعب او حول الملاعب قبل
وبعد المباراه كما كان اعلل سابقا وكان
هناك حديث مطول حديث همم دخل مطوله
همم
قال بشكل خاص يعني
يبقوا ثلاثه ساعات من دون شرب الكحول همم
كانت الطريقه ايضا ولكن صحيح ان همم
المشجعين ربما الذين همم
اعتدوا على تناول الخمر او الكحول حول
الملاعب لم نراهم بعد حتى الان على اساس
ان كما ذكرنا المشجعون الاكثر همم تواجدا
هنا اغلبيتهم همم
مشجعون الجو من الدول المجاورين اذا
معتدون على عدم همم تناول الكحول في همم
في هذه الدول الخليجيه
نعم ايضا اعتقد بالنسبه همم تحدثت عن
الجماهير لكن هناك الجاليه خاصه بالنسبه
للمشاركه العربيه وديع هناك جاليه عربيه
مقيمه في قتله في البلدان القليله القريبه
من قطر على غير الامارات او المملكه
العربيه السعوديه نتحدث عن هذه المشاركه
العربيه وتواجد تونس المغرب قطر للمره
الاولى وايضا المنتخب السعودي همم في هذه
في هذه المنطقه
تمام قبلنا امس بشكل خاص تونسي اسمه صابر
مقيم هنا في في الدوحه منذ عده سنوات يقول
ستتفاجا قال لي ستتفاجا
المشجعين التونسيين سيكون هناك عدد كبير
من التونسيين من التونسيين الحقيقيين كما
قال لي وليس من جاليات اخرى
المنتخب التونسي بقوه صحيح همم المنتخب
التونسي يلعب يوم الثلاثاء المنتخب
المغربي همم فيما بعد اذن سيصلون شيئا
فشيئا لا لا لا راينا حقيقه الامس مثلا
همم المنطقه المحطه للمشجعين التي افتتحت
انسى بشكل رسمي كان هناك عدد همم من همم
همم
ترون حاليا الافتتاح من خلفي وبعض الالعاب
الناريه التي بدات تظهر
زوقه كي يعود الى المشجعين ان التونسيين
همم هم متواجدين حاليا هنا بالنسبه همم
للمشجعين المقيمين حقيقه غدا في الدوحه
ولكن سيصلون لبعض همم من دول اخرى على
الارجح فيها الايام القليله المقبله ونفس
شيء بالنسبه للمغرب وايضا للسعوديه همم
ربما في الساعات الاخيره ايضا قبل انطلاق
المباراه الاولى لمنتخباتهم الوطنيه شكرا
لك وديعه شعار شعار
تبقى معنا خلال هذه التغطيه الخاصه
لمواكبتي افتتاح كاس العالم في قطر همم عن
هذا الكاسه عن هذه المسابقه نتحدث مع عدم
كبيره ارحب بكم مشاهده
الدوليه قبل الحديث عن الكره والرياضه
بحثا نتحدث عن هذا الجدر الذي سبق استضافه
كاس العالم في قطر همم بالنسبه للكحول كما
سمعنا مع وديع بالنسبه
الحريات والحقوق حقوق الانسان هو تحدي
كبير اذا بالنسبه لقطر
صحيح هو تحدي كبير وهذا الجدر نحن تابعناه
في السنوات الاخيره يعني منذ مونديال
البرازيل رافقه جدل مونديال روسيا رافقه
جدا وموجه قطر كذلك قوي يعني اصبحنا
معتدين على هذه وكان الغرب يقول للعالم
يجب ان تكون مثلنا اذا صح القول وعندما
قررت الفيفا ان توسع دائره الدول التي لها
الحق ان تستضيف هذه البطوله جراعينا جنوب
افريقيا همم وبلدان اخرى يعني خلاص على ان
يفهمون باننا نعيش في عالم فيه اختلافات
وفي بعض الامور لكن اعتقد بان هذا الجدل
مع صافره الانطلاقه اليوم سيبدا يندثر
يندثر وننساه صحيح بعد هم كاس العالم في
هذه النسخه لم تكن كاسابقاتها هي ت- تسمى
كاس العالم المرات الاولى يعني هي
استثنائيه في امور كثيره استثنائيه من حيث
اا يعني الموقع
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط بلد اسلامي بلد
عربي استثنائيه لان التوقيت بالضبط تاتي
في وقت يعني غير معتاد استثنائيه حتى من
الناحيه الكرويه عندك اول مره نشاهد نساء
حكمات هذه مساله يعني ايجابيه استثنائيه
من حيث الملاعب الملاعب في حاله من الغيره
الاوروبيه الى صح القول الملاعب خرافيه
يعني
احدث التكنولوجيات لان البلدان التي
اعتادت على يعني احتضان كاس العالم هذه
البلدان يا دنيا يعني لديه متطوره اصلا
لا تدفع الكثير يعني متطوره تقوم ببعض
الاصلاحات هنا وهناك لكن قطر جددت كل شيء
وعندما تجدد يعني بانك يعني نعيش في هذا
الزمن ستاتي بالجديد من حيث التكنولوجيا
ومن حيث كل شيء وهذا حاضر اما ان البيئه
والتي يعني اليسار الاوروبي هو الذي يضغط
بخصوص هذه المساله يا ريت الكل يحترم لا
مح في الولايات المتحده اكبر دوله في
العالم لا محترمه في الصين لا محترمه يعني
هو انا اعتقد بانه حتى الكلمه البارح يعني
كلامه كان فيه كثير من الحقائق يعني
الامور فيها ناس هو يتناقد والاخرون
يتناقضون يعني ازدواجيه في المعايير في كل
شيء في نهايه المطاف تنتصر دائما كره
القدم ونحن نتحدث عن لعبه شعبيه رياضيه
لاسيه الرئيس الفرنسي قالها بان يجب ايضا
هناك نفاق ايضا لان روسيا يعني عاقبوها
رياضيا لكن هذا كله هذا النفاق وهذا كل في
نهايه المطاف ستنتصر الرياضه ونحن نتحدث
عن كره القدم والمستطيل الاخضر هو الحكم
واعتقد بان العالم كله سيكب على المباريات
والتعليق ما بعد المباريات والمقاهي
والشيشه وهذه الامور عن الرياضه
الفرنسيه حامل اللقب الذي يدخل هذه
المنافسه للدفاع عن لقبه لكن منقوص ان صح
همم التعبير لعنه حامل اللقب اذا صحه
العباره ليس المنتخب الفرنسي فحسب الذي
يعاني من مثل هذا هذه اللعنه هي رافقه
المنتخب الفرنسي بعد الفوز بمونديال 98
والخروج من الدور الاول في 2002 هي الاعلى
المنتخب الالماني بعد التتويج بلقب همم
2014 والخروج من الدور الاول في مونديال
روسيا هي ليست المره الاولى لكن نعم
المنتخب الاسباني هي اكثر من المنتخب لكن
ما اردت عقب عليه هي لعنه الاصابات تحدث
عن الجدل فيما يخص المستوى السياسي في ما
يخص عده نقاط لكن عندما نتحدث رياضيا هناك
همم جدل اخر يتواجد وهو ان تقام هذه
النسخه في مثل هذه الفتره همم في مثل هذه
الفتره هناك عدد هائل من اللقاءات منذ
شهرين تقريبا بمعدل ثلاث مباراه كل ثلاثه
ايام هذا معدل
رهيب هو سبب اصابه اعتقد انها سبب اصابه
كريم بنزيما هو العدد المهول من اللقاءات
التي كان اجرها مع فريقه ريال مدريد وصل
الى المونديال باصابه طفيفه تعافى من
الاصابه ويصاب في جهه اخرى هذا الامر يعني
مهم ومهم للغايه وليس فقط كريم بنزيما
هناك احاديث هناك ليونيل ميسي يتدرب على
انفراد ان كان مصاب او يعاني من اصابته في
هذا الامر اخر يعني في الاخير اللاعب يبقى
انسان اللاعب هو يعني لا يمكنه ليس بال-
بالاله لا يمكنه الالعاب الالعاب على نطاق
عالمي ونطاق عالي بمعدل ثلاث ايام مباراه
من الحجم الكبير
هناك فتره راحه بالنسبه
شهر فقط ليست تلك الراحه ايضا وما يخرجوا
من الصيف في موسم طويل يرتاحون قليلا ما
فيه راحه هذه هؤلاء لاعبين يعني همم
من اللاعبين يقبضون الاحباب
لا انتقد اتحدث عن جدو الى اللقاء عندما
نتحدث عن القراءه
في نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا في شهر مايو
شهر خمسه واللقاء تنطلق في شهر هناك على
الاقل على الاقل قبل انطلاق هناك فريق
دوري الابطال هناك على الاقل شهر تحضيرات
هذا الجدول الزمني اثاره اكثر من مره لويس
منخار مدرب المنتخب الهولندي ان تقام مثل
هذه اللقاءات ونعلم جيدا لان هذا الموديل
ياتي بعد فتره خارجه اخرى فتره اثبت
كوميدي 19 ولا عم يعني التسلسل الاحداث
وليس انتقال
ولكن يعني امر واقع هذا الحديث فيما يخص
يعني الواقع الرياضي
الينا الان من الدوحه
الخاص عثمان اهلا بك معنا كنا في حديث همم
ربما هنا في الاستديو عثمان عن همم توقيت
اقامه هذا المنجال والاصابات ربما جدول
المباريات المكثف الذي اثر على اللاعبين
وانت بعض الاصابات منها اصابه كريم بن
زيمه الذي همم لن يتم استبداله في المنتخب
الفرنسي وفق مقال جديد ديشون همم اليوم
همم عثمان هل تحدثت مثلا الى مشجعين
فرنسيين هناك في قطر وطلبت رايهم بنسبه
لما حدثني
مساء الخير جميعا مساء الخير المشاهدين
اذن خيبه الامل كانت كبيره دنيا كيف لا
وهذا اللاعب هو الافضل في العالم هو صاحب
الكره الذهبيه همم كان قد غادر همم الحصه
التدريبيه مباشره الى احد المستشفيات حيث
خضع للعلاج وبطلب علاج الام الذي كشف على
انه مصاب على مستوى العضلات في الفخذ
الايسر وبالتالي همم الشفاء الكامل يبقى
بعد ثلاث اسابيع على الاقل وبالتالي سيغيب
بصفه رسميه خيبه امل كبيره لدى الفرنسيين
الذين كانوا يريدون ان يريدون بطالهم
والنجمهم كان بنزيما الفريق الى ابعد حد
ممكن ولما لا ربما الاطاحه بال ما يحدث
عاده لصاحب اللقب الذي عاده ما يخرج في
الدور الاول او لا يذهب بعيدا ولم يستطع
اي منتخب للحفاظ على لقبه الى منتخبان
منتخبين فقط هو المنتخب الايطالي عام 88
وايضا المنتخب البرازيلي عام 2-60
بعوده الى بما حديثكم عن الاصابات الواضح
ان لاعبي كره القدم في هذه الفتره بالذات
ربما يتعرض يتعرضون لاصابات كثيره
وبالتالي ربما الان ال- ال- يعني تعود
اصابات في هذه الفتره ليس سببه المونديال
ولكن ربما بعد العوده من المونديال
واللاعب الذي يصل الى النهائي سيجدو نفسه
بلعب حوالي همم 50 الى 60 مباراه همم في
همم الموسم وهذا كثير وكثير جدا بشهادته
المختصين على كل الواضح عن القدماء
الالهيه في صالح المنظمين وفي صالح قطر
لان الحراره اليوم وعلى عكس العاده ليست
مرتفعه تماما ان الرياح طفيفه بارده
ستساعد ومن دون شيك على تقديم اداء همم
افضل فوق الميدان ومن دون شكل سوف لن
تستخدم المبردات همم
كل ينتظر مباراه الافتتاحيه اذا عثمان قطر
والاكوادور قطر المضيف والاكوادور
القطر المدعمه بعدد كبير من مشجعها صحيح
انهم ليس في صوره المشجعين المغاربه يعني
الصراط في اي في جميع الاتجاهات والاغاني
المنظمه هم ياتون عائلات
بهدوء كبير هذا لم اشاهده انا شخصيا في
حياتي لاول مره اشاهد ملعب كره القدم في
هدوء كثيره وكاننا سنعيش لقاء في الجولف
ولكن انسان نشاهد ربما ما يقوم بها اولئك
المشجعون في المدرجات قيلتها 90 دقيقه
لمسانده الفريق المنتخب العنابي لتجاوز
هذه المقابله التي تبقى بحسب المستوى بحسب
المختصين في متناوله صحيحه على الاكوادور
له خط هجوم قوي لكن دفاعيا يبقى هش في حين
همم المنتخب العنابي الذي المنتخب القطري
العنابي الذي هو بطل لاسيا بامكانه
المفاجاه والخروج الفائزا في اول ظهور له
في كاس العالم همم فقط
يتابع هذه
انتخابات تقريبا بشكل كلي بالخصوص
المنتخبات العربيه التي تشارك في هذا
المونديال ماذا عن اخر همم الاخبار التي
تحصلت عليها بعد المنتخب كنت تتحدث عن
المنتخب القطري بقيه المنتخب العربيه اخر
اخبار التي وردت
من فين التحديات جاريه على قدمنا وساق لدى
المنتخب المغربي الذي يعمل كثيرا في تحقيق
تحقيق انجاز الثاني له بعد انجاز مونديال
مكسيكو 86 ولم خروج من دوري الى مجموعات
والتاهل في مجموعه تبقى ربما صعبه لكن في
متناوله نفس الشيء نجيده عند المنتخب
همم المجموعه التي يلعب فيها هناك بطل
للعالم ربما سيستفيدوا من الازمات الصحيه
التي يعاني منها بطل العالم منتخب فرنسا
ومباغته كما فعل يوم من المنتخب السنغالي
بقياده في مونديال 2002 عندما ازاحه بطل
العالم بالنسبه للمنتخب السعودي هو ربما
ثابته هنا في اسيا لكن على المستوى العالم
سننتظر المدرسه
ايضا مدعوما بعدد كبير من المشجعين
شكرا لك عثمان طيبي مفضل خاص كنت معنا
مباشره من قطر
هذه التغطيه الخاصه المشاهدين لكاس العالم
الذي ينطلق اليوم الحفل الافتتاحيه همم هو
يقام الان في قطر قبل المباراه الافتتاحيه
بعد نحو 40 دقيقه كنا بصدد حديث عن
المنتخبات العربيه المشاركه هذه همم قطر
طبعا البلد مضيفه السعوديه المغرب وتونس
من بين هذه المنتخبات هل هناك منتخب يمكن
ان يعتبر اكثر حظا من المنتخبات الاخرى
هو هو مونديال يعني التكهن بشكل مسبق يعني
اما يصعب لكن تبقى هناك منتخبات عربيه
المنتخب القطري عندما نشاهد هذه المجموعه
التي يتواجد فيها المنتخب القطري وهي
المجموعه الاولى قطر الاكوادور سينغال
هولندا نعلم جيدا هناك صاحب المركز الاول
وصاحب المركز الثاني هما الذين يتاهلان من
دوري المجموعات للاعب دور الثمانيه نهائي
عندما نشاهد بامكان المنتخب القطري ان
يتواجد في مركز مؤهل اي مركز او مركز ثاني
الامكانيه قائمه لكن عندما نعلم جيدا
ونشاهد فان حقيقه اعتقد ان ادم ان كان
يشاطر الراي في هذه المجموعه على الاقل ان
المنتخب السنغالي بطل افريقيا والمنتخب
الهولندي همم يعني هم الابرز هما هو
المرشح حان الاكثر لي تصدر المركزين
المؤهلين عن هذه المجموعه المركز الاول
والمركز الثاني حتى وان كان ساديو ماني
الغياب الكبيره المنتخب قال لي عن همم
والسبب سبب تبقى ايضا الاصابه الاصابه قبل
ايام قليله على الذهاب الى قطر كان يشارك
في مباراه مع فريقه بايرن ميونخ وبعد 20
دقيقه شاهدناه هناك اصطدام يبدو خلال
المباراه والخروج بشكل وتاكد الغياب ان
الاصابه لا يمكنه ان يتواجد مع مجموعه
المنتخب السنغالي في هذا الموديل لكن
عندما نشاهد الى تشكيله وتركيبه هذا
المنتخب الذي كنت واكبته وتابعته تقريب جل
اللقاءات خلال كاس امم افريقيا التي همم
كانت همم اقيمت في الكاميرون يعني منتخب
في صفوفه العتيد واللاعبين المتميزين
بامكانهم الذهاب بعيدا اعتقد ان هذا
المنتخب السنغالي ورشعه حتى في الفوز امام
المنتخب الهولندي لكن في الاخير حقيقه
الارض والميدان هي في كره القدم هي الفيصل
المنتخب الهولندي حتى من تحدث اكثر من مره
على المدرب لويس من خرجنا عالم جيد ونعرف
هذا المدرب لكن هذا وهذا المنتخب الهولندي
في صفوف اعدت لاعبين متميزين لكن هناك
فتره انتقاليه يعرفها هذا المنتخب
الهولندي ليس نفس المنتخب الهولندي الذي
شهدناه وعرفناه وتابعناه من قبل لكن هناك
اما في الاخير ان كان المنتخب القطري
بامكانه التاهل تبقى لديه الفرضيه دائما
قائمه والبدايه ستكون من الفوز بالمباراه
الافتتاحيه والحصول على النقاط ثلاث في
المباراه الاولى امام المنتخب الاكوادور
التي لن تكون بالمباراه سهله
جيدا يعني كره القدم همم اللاتينيه يعني
تبقى دائما همم متميزه اذا بالنسبه
للمنتخب الوطني المنتخب
الافضليه والاسبقيه او الافضل
وهولندا
سعوديه توجد ايضا في مجموعه صعبه فيها
الارجنتين فيها بولندا وفيها المكسيك لن
يكون رهان سهلا بالنسبه صحيح نرجع للمنتخب
القطري المستضيف هو عنده ايضا بعض النقاط
تصب في مصلحته يبقى المنتخب المستضيف لهذه
البطوله يبقى عامل الطقس يصب في مصلحته
يبقى عامل اللياقه البدنيه المنتخب القطري
اخذ راحته يعني مرتاح بدنيا اكثر من
المنتخبات كلها تقريبا هذا كله يصب في
مصلحه المنتخب القطري المنتخب السنغالي من
جهته صحيح ان هناك مجموعه متكامله تشتغل
مع بعض منذ سنوات كفريقه قوي كونه علي
سيسي لكن غياب ساديو ماني سيكون له
تداعيات ثقيله على المنتخب لماذا لان
المنتخب السنغال حتى في الكان وتابعناه
يسيطر في المباريات لكن لا يجيب صعوبات في
التسجيل مع مصر حتى في المباراه التاهيليه
الى المال لذلك كان ساجوماني هو مصدر
الثقه لهذا الفريق وهو ال- ال- الذي يكون
موجود في الاوقات الحاسمه حتى وان كان من
ضربه جزاء معنويا هذا الرجل سيؤثر على
يعني اسود التيرنجه المنتخب السعودي
باعتقد بان مجموعته تبدو اصعب من المنتخب
القطري وايضا وضعه هو يمكن يكون يعني
المنتخب القطري يعني اقوى شيء اما حاليا
همم موجوده الارجنتين والارجنتين توضع
بانها من الفرق المرشحه للفوز بهذه
البطوله وهناك ليونيل ميسي الذي يعني وان
كانت تحوم شكوك حول يعني همم يقتل البدنيه
اعتقد بان من هناك منتخب ارجنتيني صلب جدا
همم يعني الفوز عليه او حتى التعادل معه
سيكون صعب لكن كما قال هذه نبقى دائما في
كره القدم هو هذا الجميل فيها ان نقول
ونقول ونقول همم زي ما نقول احنا
بالموريتاني يعني يخرج منتخب من هنا او
هناك ويمكن يفوز او يخلق المفاجاه وهذا هو
لب التشويق في عالم كره القدم
[موسيقى]
لهذه التغطيه الخاصه طبعا وديع همم ان كنت
تتابعون في قطر كنا نتحدث عن المنتخبات
العربيه تحدث عن قطر عن السعوديه طبعا
هناك ايضا منتخب المغربي والمنتخب التونسي
همم كنا نتحدث عن حظوظ كل منتخب تحدثنا مع
هادي عن قطر ومع من ادم عن السعوديه همم
ماذا عن المنتخبين الباقيين
تونس والمغرب التونسي الذي يبدا امام اذن
ماركه تبعنا هذا المنتخب التونسي تحت
اشراف مدرب محلي جلال القادري ليست المره
الاولى التي يخوض مدرب تونسي المنتخب
الوطني في النهائيات العالميه همم المنتخب
التونسي لم يسبق له ان تتاهل الى دور ثاني
ربما هنا همم الهدف همم بالنسبه له هو
تاهل ولكن المجموعه صعبه مع منتخب فرنسا
وكذلك
ربما منتخب استراليا اقل شانئنا من سواء
المنتخبات التونسي التونسي يبدا التونسيون
يبداون ضد اذن مارك في المباراه الاولى
فيما بعد يلعبون مع استراليا في النهايه
مع هذا المنتخب الفرنسي همم
المنتخب ميزتها المنتخب التونسي انه
المنتخب الدفاعي ربما في خط الهجوم هناك
نقص همم
مشاكل له التسجيل لا يسجل كثيرا
المنتخب التونسي ولكن من اجل الفوز هنا في
المونديال عموما ليس بالضروره تسجيل عدد
كبير من الاهداف يكفي احيانا الهدف واحد
يبقى فيما بعد التراجع والدفاع عن مرمى
ربما هذه الخطه التي سيضعها المنتخب
التونسي على ما شاهدناه على كل حال في
مبارياته الاعداديه الاخيره لا سيما امام
البرازيل على ملعب فخذ دي بخانس في باريس
كان هناك هزيمه قاسيه كبيره مع تسجيل خمسه
اهداف برازيليه ولكن على مشاهدناه بشكل
خاص في الشوط الثاني لكن هناك نيه همم
اقامه حائط همم امام همم
مرمى التونسي هذا بالنسبه
سنعود ربما بعد قليل الى المنتخب المغربي
نذهب فقط الى تونس همم الحديث عن التطلعات
التونسيين لمشاركه منتخب في هذا المونديال
مع مراسل كانت في تونس سنعود اليك وديع
بعض قليل همم الان معنا من تونس العاصمه
نور الدين
نوردين مساء الخير اا طبعا اا المشاركه
التونسيه في هذا المونديال تحمل معها امان
ااه بالنسبه للتونسيين
تماما هو هناك من يتحدث ايضا تحدي حقيقي
اليوم امام المنتخب التونسي وذلك للوصول
الى الدور الثاني من هذه التصفيات خاصه
انه خلال المشاركات الست الاخيره كان
الاداء يعني متفاوت لكان كان هناك دائما
محاوله للرسول الى الدور الثاني اليوم
هناك امل لدى الجمهور التونسي في الحقيقه
الاستعدادات لهذه كاس العالم انطلقت موزه
ومده ثواب بالنسبه للمنتخب التونسي او
بالنسبه للجمهور الذي استعاده المقائي
لمتابعه هذه المقابلات كما قلت انه الهدف
هو التحدي الاساسي هو الوصول الى الدور
الثاني رغم
استعدادات المنتخب التونسي خلال اسابيع
الاخيره دعني اخوه من توتر سواء كان تتوتر
القائم بين وزاره الشباب وبين ايضا اتحاد
كره القدم وايضا حتى بين الوزاره وبين
الفيف على خلفيه الشهيره التي ذهب البعض
حتى يقاول انها ربما تهدد مشاركه المنتخب
التونسي في هذا المجال لكن تم يبدو انه تم
تجاوز كل الخلافات ولاحظنا انه في الدوحه
او في قطار هناك اليوم وزير الشباب مع
رئيس اتحاد الكره جنبا الى جنب هناك ايضا
ببعض الانتقادات التي وجهت الى المنتخب
التونسي عندما اعلن عن تشكيله التي ستشارك
في هذا المونديال كانت هناك انتقادات ليس
فقط من الجمهور انما ايضا انتقادات من
لاعبين السابقين وممرريين الذين انتقدوا
اولا وجود اربع حراس مرمى وايضا عدد من
الاختيارات الفنيه الاخرى المدرب طبعا هذا
كله سيتم تجاوزه واعتقد ان الجمهور
التونسي سيكون مع المنتخب خلال هذه الدوره
ولوحيذ ذلك من حفائه الاستقبال التي وجدها
المنتخبات التونسي من الجمهور التونسي
الموجود في الدوحه عندما وصل الى الدوحه
وكان هناك يعني ترحيب كبير جدا من قبل
التونسيين واربما هذا هو الموقف الذي
يرافق المنتخب التونسي خلال هذه التصفيات
نعم نعم
نورتينا همم في ما يخص هذه تشكيله همم هل
من همم الان هناك همم يعني الرساله التي
كانت بها وزير الشباب والرياضه الذي
يتواجد في قطر عندما نلاحظ الصوره يبدو ان
هناك يعني تقارب بين الجانب السياسي
والجامعه التونسيه لكره القدم هبتلى يعني
يبدو انه تم نسيان هذا الامر الى غايه ما
بعد المونديال لكن الان التركيز سيكون
اكثر على هذه لقاءات والرساله التي قدمها
وزير الشباب والرياضه الان فيما يخص
استدعاء هل هناك من انباء وخاصه الاشاره
الرياضي هل بامكان المنتخب التونسي السؤال
مباشر بامكانه التاهل من هذه المجموعه
مجموعه المنتخب ما مدى المارك فرنسا
يعني على الاقل من خلال الذين يتابعون
الرياضي بشكل جيد وخاصه اللاعبون السابقون
اللاعبين السابقين وايضا يعني هناك صعوبه
حقيقيه لكن هناك من يعتبر ان هذه المجموعه
بالرغم انها تضم كل من فريق الدنماركي
وايضا فريق الفرنسي لكن هناك امل لتجاوز
هذه المجموعه وامكانيه الوصول الى الدور
الثاني هناك تحدي ليس امل انما تحدي حقيقي
واعتقد انه هذا ما ركز عليه المدرب
التونسي من خلال علاقاتها على الاقل ما
قراناه في التقارير الاعلاميه انه ضروره
الوصول الى الدور الثاني وتجاوز مختلف
العقبات هو انه بامكان تحقيق الانتصارات
الممكن خلال الدوره او خلال المجموعه هذه
المجموعه الاولى نعم شكرا لك نور الدين
مراسل خاصه معنا مباشره من تونس للحديث عن
المنتخب التونسي ومشاركته في هذا
المونديال قبل ان نذهب الى المغرب تحديدا
الى الرباط ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل
اذاعه مونت كارلو الدوليه جلال مخفي يريد
تعليق بسيط من ادم بالنسبه للمنتخب
التونسي ومشاركته في هذا المونديال
المنتخب التونسي يعني اذا اعتقد بانه على
الورق يعني هو اقل حظ من المنتخبات
العربيه الاخرى بشكل عام لكن هو المنتخب
التونسي يعتدنا بانه يتاهل بطريقه يعني
دائما في علامات استفهام لكن يتاهل هو
ايطاليا ايطاليا كما يقال افريقيا ههه همم
رغم الصعوبات يعرف كيف يلعب مع في
المباريات من همم بهذا المستوى والتابعنا
ذلك في كاس العرب لا نتحدث هنا يعني هناك
فرق لكن راينا المنتخب التونسي وفي بطولات
نسخ كثيره من البطولات الافريقيه لذلك
دائما لا يحسب له ذاك الحساب بالنظر الى
الاسماء الموجوده او الظرف ذلك الظرف او
هذا الظرف همم للاعبين لكن يبقى دائما هو
المنتخب الذي خلق لك المفاجاه ويكون حاضر
في الوقت الذي لا تنتظره
اذهب الى ارض الوطن الان مع المخفي مراسل
اذاعه مونت كارلو الدوليك يا جلال مساء
الخير زن- هناك توقعات وتطلعات وامال
كبيره بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي يعقدها
المغاربه وامل طبعا تجاوز همم الدور الاول
وربما تحقيق ما حققه المغرب في 1986
مساء الخير الدنيا همم هناك طبعا امال
كبيره في يعقدها المغاربه على منتخبهم
الوطني من اجل التاهل الى الدوري الاول
رغم انه ليس الهدف المحدد همم حاليا بكل
بساطه لان المدرب همم تم تغييره في الاشهر
القليله الاخيره
وحاول ان يخلق انسجاما بين مختلف اللاعبين
وحاول تسويه الخلافات السابقه التي كانت
همم مفتعله ربما مع المدرب السابق هذه
التشكيله التي يخوض بها المنتخب المغربي
كاس العالم تعطي الكثير من الاعمال
المغاربه خاصه لانها تجمع اغلب اللاعبين
المحترفين والمنتخب المغربي هو المنتخب
الذي اكبر عدد من اللاعبين المحترفين سواء
في الدوريات الاوروبيه او دوريات الخليج
زياده نعم زياده على ذلك همم هناك دعم
كبير المنتخب على المستوى المحلي في مختلف
شوارع ومطاع ومقائه لك تم الاستعداد تم
وضع الشاشات الصغيره ومنها الكبيره في
الساحات العامه تم تقديم عروض لتشجيع
الناس على الحضور والتشجيع والمشاركه تم
الطباعه قمصان المنتخب والعائلات والاطفال
كذلك يقتلون هذه القمصان من اجل حضور
لمختلف المنتخب المباريات التي سيخذها
المنتخب المغربي وبعض الشركات في المغرب
همم قامت بتقسيس وقت هذه حتى يتمكنوا يمكن
ان يحس بها في المغرب يعني في هذه الاثناء
طبعا حمى كاس العالم حاضره دائما سواء
تعلق او حمى اسود الاطلس حاضره دائما سواء
تعلق الامر بكاس العالم او بمباريات
اقليميه او خاصه بالقاره السمراء في
المغاربه يتابعون تفاصيل تفاصيل المنتخب
وضغط بشكل او باخر على الجامعه الملكيه
لكره القدم وكذلك على المدرب من اجل
الاستقدام اللاعبين الذين كانت معهم بعض
الخلافات وقد نجحوا في ذلك لانه يرون ان
هؤلاء اللاعبين يستحقون ان ينضموا الى
المنتخب اقصائيات كاس العالم شكرا لك يا
شباب
نتحدث مع مراسلنا من المغرب عن المنتخب
المغربي وامال هذا المنتخب طبعا في هذه
النسخه من المنزار والسكانها هناك اسماء
مهمه ومتميزه في تشكيلته
تمام انا تشكيله المدرب الجديد وليد رجب
تحدث مراسلون عن تغيير المدرب قبل فتره
قليله مع اقصاء المدرب السابقه
في نفس الوقت كل شيء كان يدور من حوله
وربما
اداره الجامعه
حقيقيه الان تغيير المدرب ربما كل شيء
اعاده الى طبيعته بعوده اللاعبين كما ذكر
المراسلنا جلال عوده همم بشكل خاص للاعب
تشيلسي وعوده الى الهدوء من هذه الناحيه
عندما ننظر المتابع المنتخب المغربي في
السابق او هنا في الدوحه نرى طبعا همم
منتخب مختلف همم حتى همم تنظيم مختلف عن
ربما بقيه المنتخبات العربيه والافريقيه
ولقيت تنظيم اوروبي حقيقه همم دنيا تعامل
اوروبي اا مع خارج وايضا مع الدخل ما عدد
كبير من اللاعبين المحترفين في اوروبا هو
منتخب حقيقه يشبه المنتخبات الاوروبيه
اكثر من منتخبات اخرى
ليستعد ويستعد بهذه الطريقه مع العديد من
اللاعبين المكونين في الخريف في فرنسا في
هولندا وفي بلجيكا وهناك معامله على
الطريقه الاوروبيه ربما هذا سيساعد هذا
المنتخب المغربي في الدوري الاول مع
مواجهات مع منتخبات اوروبيه تحديدا بلجيكا
وكرواتيا بشكل خاص بالمنتخب الكرواتي في
المباراه الافتتاحيه يوم الاربعاء المقبل
الافتتاحيه بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي همم
بتوع المنتخب كرواتيا التي خاضها النهائي
في موسكو قبل اربع سنوات ولكن ايضا تجديد
في هذا المنتخب وهنا المتابعون يعتبرون ان
هذه المباراه ربما ستكون مفتاح هذه
المجموعه اذا تمكن المنتخب المغربي من
التغلب على كرواتيا وهذا باستطاعته ان
يفعل ذلك همم ربما سيفتح امامه الطريق من
اجل التاهل الى الدور ثمن النهائي وهذا
همم هو همم
الجامعه المغربيه الجامعه الملكيه
المغربيه المغربيه
في اليوم الاخير يظهرون في اليوم الاخير
خلافا لربما طبيعه الجمهور التونسي الذي
يحب ان يحتفل وان يظهر دائما باكرا عده
ايام قبل همم لقاءات المنتخب شكرا لك
وديعه يعني همم كنت همم معنى طبعا من
الخورفي قطر همم عود الى الاستديو نوصل
الحديث عن هذا المنتخب المغربي هذه
المنتخب المغربي المدرب طبعا وليد
الركراكي همم ياسين بونو اشرف حكيمي
رومانسي حكيم زياش اسماء كبيره تلعب في
دوريات اوروبيه همم
قد تساعد هذا المنتخب ربما في بلوغ هدفه
اكيد اكيد اكثر من مره وتعودنا وتحدثنا
وتابعنا هذا المنتخب المغربي ان كان على
المستوى التنظيمي اي ما توفره الجامعه
الملكيه المغربيه لهذا المنتخب توفر كل
الامور حتى يكون
الراحه التامه والتركيز على اللقاء وتقديم
نتائج متميزه على مستوى التشكيله وقيمه
لاعبين بالنسبه للمنتخب المغربي اذا اردنا
بقيه المنتخبات اعتقد ان الافضل يبقى هو
المنتخب المغربي ان كان على مستوى
التشكيله وكما ذكر ربيع
حتى همم حتى اوروبيه يمكن مقرراته بعدت ان
منتخبات اوروبيه على مستوى القيمه ما ينقص
هذا المنتخب المغربي وشاهدناها اكثر من
مره ان كان في المنافسات القاريه مع
الافريقيه او كان في المنافسات العالميه
همم في المونديال هو كيفيه تقطير هذا الكم
الهائل من اللاعبين هو هذا الامر الذي
يثير كثير من ال- من الجدول والمشكل
بالمقائدنا للمنتخب المغربي الذي كان من
بين الافضل او ابرز المنتخبات التي كانت
ستراها على اللقب الافريقي في الكاميرون
هو المنتخب المغربي وشاهدناه خرج فنيا
كرويا يمكنه تقديم الافضل والحصول على
النتائج الجيده لكن كان هناك مشكل تاطير
مشكل اشرنا وتحدثنا عن وحيد الجدل الذي
كان يرافق هذا المدرب ان كان كان اشرف على
التدريب المنتخب الجزائري وشاهدناها كيف
المستويات التي كان قدمها مع المنتخب
الجزائري خاصه في مونديال 2014 لكن مع
المنتخب المغربي لم كان هناك كم هائل من
المشاكل الابرز كانت محاكم زياش حتى ان
ذهب اكثر من مره وهناك وعندما شاهدنا على
الكثير على غرار همم
مراسل مونت كارلو الدوليه كان اشار الى
عوده حاكم زياش الشارع المغربي الشارع
الرياضي هو الذي كان وراء عوده زياش في
الاخير رئيس الجامعه الملكيه المغربيه
يعني تقبل رد او مطالبه الشارع المغربي
لكن اللاعب كان عندما تحدث اكثر من مره
قال بان بما ان وحيد الجيش يتواجد على راس
الاداره الفنيه للمنتخب المغربي فان عودته
لن تكون للمشاركه للمنتخب المغربي اذا
شاهدنا ايضا على مستوى ذكرت بعض الاسماء
اسماء المنتخب المغربي تقريبا على جنب
الخطوط هناك نجوم من حراسه المرمى ياسين
بونو يتميز ويقدم مستوى رائعه في الدوري
الاسباني وانا اتحدث انه قد يغادر حتى
فريق اشبيليا فريق اشبيليه اعتقد انه
بامكانه هناك انديه عالميه كبرى تريد ظفر
بخدمات يسبون وان كان على وسط الدفاع الذي
تحدث عن حكيمه حكي في تقريبا من بين ابرز
الاظهر على الجهه اليمنى على المستوى
العالمي ليس فقط على المستوى الافريقي او
المغاربيه الحكيمي يعتبر من بين الافضل
هناك نقاط استفهام تطرح وتثار على مستوى
خط الامامي للمستوى للمنتخب المغربي اكثر
من مره وكاني هناك نقص النجع نقص نجاح على
مستوى الخط الامامي وتسجيل الاهداف كما
ذكر منذ قليل الوديع في المونديال وفي هذا
الدور المجموعات لا يجب ان تسجل كل مباراه
خمسه اهداف بامكانك ان تسجل هدف
تحصل على 3 نقاط تدفعك للتاهل للدور
المقبل وفيما بعد حتى وان كانت نتيجه
سلبيه صفر بصفر بالامكانك التاهل بعد
اللجوء الى ضربات الجزاء الترجيحيه هذا هو
حقيقه همم المونديال وحقيقه كاس امم همم
ان كانت اوروبا وامم افريقيا وشهادنا ان
المنتخب الايطالي كما اشار همم ادم منذ
الفرق بين الايطاليه واللعب المانيا
اوروبا وقارنه بالمنتخب التونسي ان كان هو
يعني ايطاليا افريقيا او يعني هو اا على
الصعيد التكوين لكن هناك مشاكل اعتقد لا
يمكن لا يمكننا مقارنه الوضع الداخلي
للمنتخب المغربي على المستوى التنظيمي على
المستوى الهيكليه بالوضع الذي يعيشه
المنتخب التونسي
على مستوى التنظيمي يمكن اعتبار
النتائج لا اعتقد لان في الاخير دائما ما
كان المنتخب الايطالي وهو من ابرز
المنتخبات المتوجه بلقب العالمي لا يتواجد
في هذا المجال لا يقدم كره جميله لكن يحصل
على النتائج هذا ربما
فطرني منذ تغيير هذه الخطه وتقديم الكره
المنتخب المغربي ويعني فقد الكثير فقد
الكثير عندما اراد تقديم كره جميله همم في
همم عده مباريات ومن بين نقاط السلبيه عدم
تواجد في هذا المونديال يعني منتخب
مونديال ايطاليا يعتقد هناك همم غائبه عن
العرس الكروي العالمي لهذا الامر فان
المنتخب التونسي بامكانه الخروج من دور
المجموعات لك امر صعب وصعب للغايه البدايه
ستكون بهذه المواجهه امام الدنمارك ان كان
همم تحصل حتى على نقطه ان كان لم ينهزم
الماده تبقى
اصعب من فرنسا فرنسا
امام هذا المنتخب بلدان مركز صعوبات كبيره
وجدها المنتخب الفرنسي
اعتقد ان هذه تبقى همم تحدثنا عن هيكليه
وهمم يعني عندما نشاهد ان هناك منتخب
بلجيكي لكن ليس بين نفس المنتخب البلجيكي
الذي شاهدناه في مونديال روسيا وليس نفس
المنتخب البلجيكي الذي شاهدناه قبل اربع
في 2016 في امم اوروبا هنا في فرنسا ليس
نفس المنتخب هناك تراجع كبير على مستوى
المنتخب البلجيكي لهذا فان اعتقد ان
المنتخب المغربي اضعه من بين المنتخبات
التي ستتحصل وستتاهل في هذه المجموعه
والمجموعه السادسه
كلمه للمنتخب
السوريا يعني هذه السلاح ذو حدين يعني اذا
كنت تريد ان تلعب مثل الاوروبيين عليك
تكون على مستواهم او تكون افريقيه او كن
لديك يعني همم طريقه اللاعب التي تلعب بها
تقييد بان ان يعني اوروبيا واضعف من
كروازيا واضعف من بلجيكا يعني ستخرج همم
نفس الحاله تنطبق على السنغال يعني لجميع
اللاعبين السنغالين يلعبون خارج السنغال
لا يعني
تمارسوا المهنه خارج السنغال لكن في بطوله
مثل هذه يجب ان تكون هناك اللياقه البدنيه
هي النقطه السر في اللياقه البدنيه وهمم
يعني الذهنيه اوروبيون لا ينتصرون على
العالم فقط لان لديهم كره جميله لا الكره
جميله في امريكا اللاتينيه الذهنيه
وبالتكيف مع المباريات والتكتيك وهذه هي
المدرسه الاوروبيه وليد الركراكي والجميل
في المنتخبات العربيه الافريقيه تونس
والمغرب اذا ما اضفنا اليه من السنغال
والمنتخبات الافريقيه بشكل عام اول مره
تدخل المنجال بمدربين افارقه محليين فقط
يعني النقطه جميله جدا لكن ايضا فيها
الكثير من التحديات ولكن تبقى نقطه
ايجابيه لان انا اعتقد بان المنتخبات
الوطنيه وهذا يقول الكافرون يجب ان يدربها
اذا همم كانت هناك امكانيه مدرب وطني وهذا
ما يحصل مع المنتخبات الافريقيه وما هناك
مجموعه من المدربين رجراجي قدم اداء رائع
مع الوداد البيضاوي
ونفس الحال بالنسبه لي مدرب يعني التونسي
وان كانت يعني
رافق همم يعني المنذر به ما حصل لكن لديه
تجربه ويبقى قادر واحتكاك بهؤلاء اللاعبين
ليس همم كان موجود في دكه البدلاء لم ي
همم
الكاميرون اسطوره الدفاع الكاميروني نقطه
ايجابيه
لا حتى تحدث عن مدرب الكاميروني سونج ايضا
كان يعني
نعرفها اكثر كلام اقصد انا عارفه اكثر
كلام لكن كمدرب اقل اي كمدرب ما عنده خبره
ولكن الكلاعب كان يعني لاعب كبير اتحدث
هنا عن قوم هؤلاء كلهم افارقه عن
الايجابيه في هذه النقطه لكن الان الحين
الاختبار والتحدي كبير وسنرى
ليس اكثر
نهائيا بين المغرب
ههه لما لا لما لا لان هذه النقطه يا دنيا
نحن نستهزا لكن مهمه يجب ان تكون انا
اعتقد ما يحصل للافارقه بانهم يدخلون
المونديال غير مؤمنين صحيح انت يمكن تكون
يعني مستواك مثل همم
بانك قد تخلق المفاجاه وعندما تدخل بعقليه
انهزاميه يعني ستهزم امام اي فريق ما
يفعله يعني صغيره منه الجميع لكن هذا محفز
فريق مثل السنه قال اليوم لماذا لا يقول
انا قادر ان اهزمه هولندا وان اصل الى
النهائي يعني لديه جيل ذهبي لكن يدخل
افارقه دائما بعقليا همم
همم بحكم منصبه كرئيس رئيس الاتحاد
الكاميروني وامور كثيره لكن يجب على الاقل
ان ياخذ الافارقه هذا التصريح بطريقه جديه
شيئا ما وان ايجابيه
مهمه جدا في عالم كره القدم
التتويج باللقب بالعالم
يعني افضل اللاعبين على المستوى في
البطولات الاوروبيه اللاعبين افارقه تاتي
يعني حتى وان كانت تكوين الاوروبي فان
الاصل يعني همم ينتمون للعديد من
المنتخبات الافريقيه قرات ايضا التعليق
اذا كان وديع معنا اولها عن ابرز
المنتخبات المرشحه تحدثنا عن المشاركه
العربيه تحدثنا عن المشاركه الافريقيه
نتحدث ان كان ودي عن افضل زي المنتخبات
المرشحه اللقب حامل اللقب المنتخب الفرنسي
هناك منتخب برازيلي مدجج بالنجوم في هذا
همم
هذا المجال لكن ايضا هناك منتخب ارجنتيني
متميز اعتقد وديع حتى قبل ان ننهي هذه
التغطيه الخاصه ان كان معنا وديع همم نربط
الاتصال بوديعا كان معنا فيما يخص ابرز
المنتخبات التي ستراها على هذا اللقب ليس
معنا وديع ان نتحدث عن هذا في الاستوديو
مع ادم ابرز المنتخبات تبقى اعتقد هذا
المنتخب البرازيلي المدجج بالنجوم وايضا
ايضا منتخب في غياب المنتخب بريطاني هناك
منتخب قوي على المستوى الدفاع والمنتخب
وسط الميدان هو المنتخب الارجنتيني
بالاضافه الى نجم وعندما يكون 100 ليونيل
ميسي يعني يمكن تقديم الافضل في هذا
البرازيل يعني يدخل المجال هو متصدر
تصنيفه والبرازيل عندما ننظر الى ما بعد
روسيا همم وخروجه تشتغل كثيرا على هذا
الفريق هناك فريق صلب جدا في جميع الخطوط
مدجاج بالمواهب يعني حراسه المرمى
لدينا الثنائيه عندما ترى منتخب يترك يعني
فيرمينو مش محتاج يعني للهجوم وفي خط
الوسط هناك همم مزيج من الشباب والخبره
الهجوم نفس الشيء الدفاع نفس الشيء يعني
عندما تنظر الى هذا المنتخب بشكل عام
وتنظر الى المنتخبات الموازيه الى صحه
القول يعني اتحدثنا عن المنتخب الارجنتيني
يبقى هو المنافس الاقرب للبرازيل وفاز
عليه في كوبا امريكا
الجديد في المنتخب الارجنتيني وهذه المره
هو بانه
يمتلك الدفاع عمومه دفاعيه الصلبه والكره
الحديثه دافع جيدا وبعدين نشوف والامام
فيه ميسي
الايطاليه هذه هي النقطه الايجابيه في
الارجنتين لكن البرازيل يعني تساوي في
جميع الخطوط المنتخب الفرنسي مدرسه يعني
الدفاع يعني الدشنا يعني همم
مين القطه يجب ان يكون هناك من ينفذها
للاسف الشديد
[موسيقى]
صعوبات كثيره يبقى البرازيل مرشح الاكبر
امامه الكل يتحدث عن عوده البطوله الى
امريكا اللاتينيه لكن هناك لاتيني الهواء
اخر منتخب البرتغالي يمكن ان تكون له كلمه
المنتخب الانجليزي مدجج بالنجوم
الاوروبيون ايضا لديهم منتخبات المنتخب
الفرنسي رغم مصائب ومشاكله يبقى منتخب
يحسب له حساب
وهناك المنتخبات المفاجاه ايضا انا اضع
بينها المنتخب الدنماركي الذي يمتلك منتخب
فريق قوي في جميع الخطوط ويتكيف مع جميع
الظروف واا سنرى يعني لا يمكن ان يجزم
المنتخب
الافريقي منتخب افريقي سيكون مفاجاه هذا
الموديل انا اي حقيقه بين السنغال والمغرب
بين السنغال والمغرب اعتقد ان احد همم يا
اما السنغال او المغرب سيكون في ادوار
متقدمه في هذا الموضوع
من يمكن ان يفوز باللقب ادم بنسبه لك
ترشيحك هو بيقول هي مش مفاجاه لانه منتخب
عريق لكن فاز بها مره واحده وهو من اخترع
اا اخترع كره القدم المنتخب الانجليزي
الانجليزي اعتقد ان المنتخب البرازيلي
حاجات طبيعيه ههه
مرشح الاول مرشحك انت ترشح البرازيل هذه
البرازيل انا اتحفظ ههه
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا ناتي همم بهذا الى ختام
هذه التغطيه الخاصه التي تابعتموها على
افغان كاتو على اسيره اذاعه مونت كارلو
الدوليه كان معي في الاستوديو لتقديم هذه
التخطي- هذه العجمي همم ضيفي وزميلي في
اذاعه مونت كارلو الدوليه ادب من همم قطر
كان معنا وديع في اعاني وعثمان الطيبي
وكان معنا ايضا من تونس نور الدين باركي
مراسل
المخفي من المغرب
شكرا لكم على المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]